HERE IN THIS BUILDING TESTED BY.
GETS IT BACK OUT, THE SHOT
CHANGES DIRECTION AND THE SHOT.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S OFF TOP FIVE
OR SIX, NOW IN THE BOTTOM
THIRD.
WON FOR THE LASTSTUDBRANSON.
HOW DID THAT NOT GO IN?
BACK A
TRIED TO FIND A HOLE.
>> Keith: THISHAYES LOOKING ACR.
WE'LL SEE IF HE WORKS HIS WAY
NOW FOR THE
FLAMES.
LUCIC'S PASS INTERCEPTED,
SHOVELED OUT TO CENTER OUT OF
THEIR REACH FF THE POST AND
GETS RIGHTAS WELL.
GREAT JOB IN HELPING HIM GET
OUT OF THAT PENALTY BOX WITHOUT
A GOAL B. HAD
THAT ONE, THAT'S HOW
RISTOLAINEN FEELS, RISTOLAINEN
TO HAYES, A PASS, A SHOT, O PAS.
GOES OFF ANDERSON'S FEET.
THERE IS A GOOD STEEL BY
RISTOLAINEN AND WATCH HAYES THE
GIROUX AFTER THE PUCK.
TIED AT ONE.
LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO.
CARTER HART WITH A GREAT SAVE
ON JOHNNY GAUDREAU ONCE AGAIN
AND D O PLAY IT IN. BACK TO
THE BOARDS AND NOW IT'S HAYES,
MOVE IT TO YANDLE BACK TO KEVIN
HAYES.
GET THE LEGS GLOVE AND CHIPPINAS
MacEWEN AGAIN DOING THE JOB.
TH DAN GLOVED DOWN.
PLAYED BACK OUT OF THE BOOT OF
MANGIAPANE, T, SAVE,
REBOUND MacEWEN, AND  MARKSTROM
HOLD HIS OWN AND MAKESTHESE
SHOTS.CK DEFLECTS OUT AND THERES
GAUDREAU.
RE IN THE
FLYERS REALLY WITH A SHOT
MENTALITY EARLY IN TTHROUGH HIS
AND MARKSTROM AGAIN HOT, DEFLEC
AND HART MAKES THE SAVE IT.
COUTURIER TO VAN RIEMSDYK,
CENTERS IT IN FRONT, LAUGHTON
COULDN'T GET MUCH ON THAT SHOT
AS HE WAS BEING CHECKED.
NOW
THE SHOT AND TRIED THE PASS.
SULLIVAN WAS THERE